we're all solving for the same core
problems
we're all trying to move people from
resistance to commitment we're all
trying to get to the truth and use the
truth to make better relate to build
better relationships to make better
decisions to arrive at better outcomes
so when i saw the opportunity to
integrate these interview and
interrogation perspectives and
techniques with the business research
and best practices
figured why not took the leap and here
we are
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders where we're going to be talking
about communication probably the most
fundamental aspect in all of our lives
we're going to be talking to michael
readington a cfi certified forensic
interviewer who's going to be sharing
with me a little bit about interviewing
communication techniques not just for
you know
police forces or secret service forces
but but also for real life for leaders
for management for anything in our
relationships
meet michael cfi a certified forensic
interviewer and president of inquisitive
inc which integrates key components of
effective non-confrontational interview
techniques with current business
research for executives
in his book the disciplined listening
method how a certified forensic
interviewer unlocks hidden value in
every conversation
reddington draws on his background in
forensics and his understanding of human
behavior through interrogation to teach
readers how to improve their listening
communication and relationship building
skills and how to use the truth to their
advantage
a forensic interviewer by training today
are the president of inquasiv inc
and and this conversation is all about
listening and interviews and being on
just better leaders better communicators
and so i'm definitely looking forward to
hearing your feedback from me
later on but for now i want to learn a
little bit about you know your
experience forensic interviewer what
that means and how we can take some of
the insights and key learnings that
you've had
working with people in your career and
translating them to sort of our daily
life as entrepreneurs as executives as
team leaders and team builders so again
thank you for being here michael and
tell me a little bit about sort of your
your career what does it even mean to be
a forensic interviewer
i appreciate you asking my career
thus far has been the accumulated
results of many accidents and unforeseen
opportunities to be honest i don't know
that at any point in time i set out or
had a of the long-term plan to do what i
do it's just all come together but to to
get back and answer your question about
a certified forensic interviewer
the certified for
for someone to use the term certified
forensic interviewer means that they
have earned the designation so that
would be like a certified project
manager certified public accountant i
mean like many other professional
certifications so in order to qualify
certain prerequisites have to be met
then the exam has to be passed of course
and then all of the re-education credits
and those things have to be taken after
the fact so the
the designation in itself isn't
necessarily
a career designator there are certified
forensic interviewers in the private
sector in the audit space in federal
government and law enforcement and in
many different industries
really is certified forensic
interviewers we are charged with
obtaining the truth the truth is our
goal guilt or innocence is never the
goal truth is always the goal in
obtaining the truth through legally
morally and ethically acceptable
standards believe it or not people are
often surprised with what they will
learn
when they're nice to somebody
when they treat them with respect and
allow them to save face so really
certified forensic interviewers we use
rapport based techniques to encourage
people to share sensitive information
under vulnerable circumstances
that quite often involves the potential
for consequences
interesting and so i i'm hearing a lot
of trust coming into this a lot of
relationship building hey let's say the
you know what what some people may
perceive from television shows fear
tactics a good bad cop psychological
maneuvers etc this is about building a
relationship through a conversation
through listening and and trust is that
correct
it is correct and one way to illustrate
that is the difference between actually
two difference the first difference
between commitment and compliance
yes we can use heavy pressure techniques
in any given situation to in a sense
force somebody to comply with whatever
it is we want them to do now if we just
separate compliance and commitment
compliance is essentially obeying a
command commitment is a lining up our
self-image with whatever it is we're
being tasked to do because we feel like
at least in part it is our idea
generally compliance results in the
minimum required amount of time
attention quality follow-up attention to
detail where commitment on the other
hand tends to be longer lasting a
greater attention to quality detail
personal ownership and those things
so if somebody at all feels forced into
compliance or coerced to any degree to
share information to your point trust
doesn't exist the relationship isn't
going anywhere at best this is a
short-term win for the person looking
for information that's assuming there's
a reasonable level of accuracy to the
information that they've actually
obtained which there may not be
which is why to your point bringing up
trust it's also important to him to
understand the difference between trust
and faith
taking all religious connotations out of
this piece of the compensation for sure
people tend to trust what they have
tangible evidence of
they tend to have faith in the things
that they believe in strongly but often
lack that tangible evidence so whether
we're leaders in the conference room
whether we are business developers out
in the in the boardroom whether we are
investigators in the interview or
interrogation room
if we aren't communicating in a way that
provides people with tangible evidence
that they can trust us
that it's going to be incredibly
difficult to establish the bonds
necessary to acquire the information to
build the relationships moving forward
so really understanding the key
differences there in both instances is
quite important
how did you get into all this from the
get-go how did this all start for you
honestly entirely by accident i started
out as a special education teacher and
baseball coach i love myself to get peer
pressure yeah allowing myself to get
peer pressured into trying the financial
industry where i lasted for two years
one month in two days no offense to
anybody who currently enjoys working in
the financial industry but who's
counting it
you can tell i enjoy the experience of
that much
um went back to school to get a business
degree was juggling part-time jobs to
pay the bills ended up with a part-time
job in security and that job has since
burned wildly out of control uh so
part-time became full-time full-time
became management eventually i was asked
to interrogate somebody who was
suspected of death activity to this day
i still can't tell you why he confessed
but he did
and that led to
my
pursuit of additional training
additional education expansion of role
eventually earning my certified forensic
interviewer designation
then thankfully being recruited to join
the world leader in non-confrontational
interview and
and advising a company called wz i
worked with them for a decade conducting
contract interrogations and traveling
the world teaching interrogation
techniques to law enforcement federal
agents private sector
and then based on some of the things
we're talking about now realize the
opportunity to take some of these
prospective tools and techniques into
the world of business because the more i
worked with business leaders even an
investigative role the more it became
crystal clear that in their business
communications negotiations business
development conversations leadership
conversations to relate to your world a
little bit investment conversations due
diligence conversations interviews and
interrogations we're all solving for the
same core problems we're all trying to
move people from resistance to
commitment we're all trying to get to
the truth and use the truth to make
better relations to build better
relationships to make better decisions
to arrive at better outcomes so when i
saw the opportunity to integrate these
interview and interrogation perspectives
and techniques with the business
research and best practices
figured why not took the leap and here
we are
so so what do we often do wrong you know
i'm sure there's a lot but what do we as
you know
to the traditional leaders um what do we
do wrong as we try to
to move people from resistance to
commitment i love that statement
i appreciate that and i don't think i
love that the fact that you asked it
that way what do we do wrong
in fairness
we only know what we've been taught we
only know what we've experienced and
often as we grow up think about the
leaders that we have in our lives right
parents teachers coaches advisers
managers in our early jobs depending on
how much fun your listeners had maybe a
lawful law enforcement officer here and
there
if we think about those conversations
they're generally telling us what to do
and what not to do
lucky right if we are lucky they're
telling us why but generally
people in in those roles as we grow i
spend a whole lot of time telling us
what to do or what not to do so we learn
by experience and we end up becoming
operationally conditioned to assume that
that is the optimum way for us to
communicate when it becomes our turn
so as we look for opportunities to
evolve from there really one of the
first things that we talk about is
owning responsibility for our
counterparts communication experiences
that if if you and i are having a
conversation and it starts to go off the
rails if i sit back and say well that's
a michael problem
as a matter of fact that's not true
that's enough problem because if there's
something that we need to achieve
together and i sit back and say well if
he doesn't like it that's a michael
problem if he doesn't understand it
that's a michael problem it's not it's a
me problem so the first is understanding
that it's not so much about what we want
to say or do but if we are looking to to
use your words establish trust create
the bonds necessary to move
relationships and objectives forward
it's all about creating communication
experiences
so from a preparation standpoint i don't
want to think what do i want to say to
michael
i need to think what does michael need
to experience before he chooses to
commit
to either share the information or take
the action that i need him to and now
it's my responsibility to create that
communication experience
and i can even take that a step further
and think to myself
i want to be sure that i don't fall prey
to my own preconceived notions
assumptions biases all these things that
continue to get talked about every day
so instead of asking myself why should
michael share this information or take
this action which makes me feel like i'm
considering your perspective but in
reality i'm transposing mine on top of
yours
what i want to ask myself is why
shouldn't michael
share this information or take this
action
and it's not about being negative it's
not about expecting failure it's about
me being brutally honest with myself
dialing up my empathy as much as
possible and truly trying to understand
your situation not from a position of
potentially overvaluing what i bring to
the table but the opposite potentially
undervaluing it like if i was michael
and i had everything going on in his
world that i'm aware of why would he not
want to do business with me why would he
not want to tell me this why would he
not want to do this and because i'm old
school i'll actually get a pen and paper
and write that down
once i write that down that's when i
look at myself and ask okay now in order
to use this to my advantage to get the
outcomes i need how do i create the
communication experience as necessary
i think part of that gap or part of
clearing that gap is realizing that
often i find myself
thankfully invited to join rooms of
super smart super successful people
that are struggling trying to find
rational solutions to emotional problems
hmm
interesting
wow often when we're trying to move
people from resistance to commitment we
look at it rationally you know your
business you know what you do you know
what's made you and your team successful
and for you and i say you at this point
is the royal you sure it's easy for
people in successful positions to look
out at the field and say i know how this
movie ends i can see 10 moves ahead this
all makes sense to me how come it
doesn't make sense to anybody else well
we're looking at it rationally with the
people who were involved with are going
through a series of emotional
experiences so trying to find rational
solutions takes us back to the
old-fashioned square peg round hole so
those would be a few opportunities to
start
and so what type of work do do you often
do with leaders to
to help us you know get into this right
mindset i'm hearing a lot of you know
there's a there are certain qualities
that we probably emphasize more so than
others such as empathy and uh rational
versus emotional you know those types of
those types of ideas but how does that
how do these ideas get translated
tangibly to work
within teams or leaders
i appreciate you asking and if i may
i'll throw one more on top yeah just
please you say that um believe it or not
expertise often makes it more difficult
for us to list
yeah i can imagine that the more
expertise somebody has the easier it is
to get lost in their own internal
monologue feel like they know how the
movie ends there's no need to listen
i've got it all figured out hurry up and
let me get to say what i want to say so
again with leaders that falls into play
as well
so to circle back and answer your
question thank you
our team spends the majority of our time
training and advising so it could be
one-on-one small group or customized
team training or one-on-one or small
group advising and either can be built
around general topics that we work with
the group to solve real problems in real
time many are custom designed from the
very start to make sure that we're
tackling the specific issues to achieve
the specific goals that any leader or
group is facing at that time
incredible and does that work usually
what one-on-one with leaders is it
usually group work
what what type of work do you do
both so one-on-one is fairly common and
now as we've all gotten used to video
it's becoming even more common but we do
a lot of group work as well whether
that's with leadership teams management
teams leadership cohorts
sales teams hr teams we do a fair amount
of group work as well
but but this sounds like these are
things that are relevant for anybody in
any profession i mean in any
conversation that anybody has whether
it's in their personal lives in their
marriage in their professional work with
their boss or their employees right i
mean these are sort of global standards
right
well i'm biased but i'm going to say
yeah i'm going to say yes but it's true
the the way that we reference it is it
applies to all of our high value
interactions and when you think about
our high value interactions that could
be a conversation my wife and i need to
have tonight that could be a
conversation with my son on the way to
school tomorrow morning of course all of
the business conversations that we
participate in in our personal lives
making purchases negotiating
opportunities you know i have a young
son conversations that i need to have
with his teachers or his coaches you
know they might not seem like a big deal
but they're high value conversations
considering the impact that they have on
my son so yes to your point any of our
high-value conversations for sure
how do you find that people's
perceptions of conversations or
relationships change as a result of this
work um i imagine that it's
for instance like if i try to envision
myself doing this work probably get a
little bit less disappointed in
situations because they were better able
to understand where why the other person
is saying or doing whatever they're
doing
yes so generally it results in a higher
level of situational awareness a better
understanding of where people are coming
from what they might be feeling what the
other impacts on the conversation may be
and also a more strategic approach
people shifting more towards a longer
game as opposed to a shorter game i hate
to use the words win and lose but i know
we have a short time frame here so if
i'm trying to accomplish a goal in one
conversation that might be really
difficult but if i can plan well enough
ahead and i've got three or four
conversations over a longer runway now
that gives me more time to build a
relationship learn along the way
identify a new path and build that goal
so higher level of self-awareness
situational awareness a little bit more
that long game strategic outlook those
are all some of the perspective shifting
outcomes that we see
tell me a little bit more about you know
where your passion lies so now that
you're
you've gone through the certifications
and your work you know why why do you do
what you do why do you work with other
leadership teams and help others through
this you know you could be employing a
lot of these things for different
positions that are amazing and they're
they're
super interesting super sensitive why
why choose to do in kuwait to be the
president
instead of that
i appreciate you asking you know for me
as i look back over my career and of
course i need to include my former
teammates on this as well
and i i don't say this
with sarcasm i mean this is true
we were very lucky
that we were responsible for having
conversations with people who wanted
nothing to do with us
and the people who paid us to have those
conversations had very high expectations
of them
so literally we had to go in and
create opportunities to bond with people
in very unlikely circumstances who had
far more information to far more
motivation excuse me to withhold
information and to share it
and because of that we were able to
develop and fine-tune and explore
communication techniques on both sides
of the coin the strategic observation
and the persuasive communication in
order to consistently arrive at unlikely
results acquiring this information
ending conversations on a handshake
everybody at least for the time being
feels better when we walk out of the
room
and because of that i truly believe and
receive the feedback fairly regularly
that this these approaches it's not just
one but these approaches to
conversations
are novel to people that have never been
in that opportunity or they've never had
the the need to think or communicate
that way so it now all becomes all about
increasing impact how many people can we
touch how many relationships can we
touch how many outcomes can we create
how can we use
a thought process some skills and
techniques that are often employed in
this little niche world and bring them
out to the greater world in order to
increase what we can all accomplish and
to me there's there's
some real exciting possibilities with
that
is there a point where
you do need the conversation to go one
way you know in in sort of this
strategic of thinking that you're saying
okay at some point i realized that this
method is not necessarily working and
and i need to resort to confrontation or
there are some other steps you need to
take i mean and and how do you
distinguish when you've tried enough
when you've played the long enough game
that you can now sort of compromise on
that and go to the other
to the other situation
i appreciate you asking and the answer
to that is yes
for me i think about it like the
speedometer on a car i'm sorry the
tachometer on a car so if i redline the
engine i risk blowing it up right away
so if i redline in a conversation i risk
blowing up the conversation blowing up
the relationship right away you know you
can't unpick a fight but if i bring the
revs up just enough as necessary and
then bring them back down i can continue
to manage their relationship but yes you
know one of the things that we think
about and i don't mean to sound nebulous
with it is the totality of circumstances
what am i trying to accomplish who am i
trying to accomplish it with what are
the longer term goals or risks that this
is attached to what's the time frame
that i have available to do this what
are some of the other
factors in play and considering those
totality of circumstances yes that can
dictate how long the long game lasts
when i need to turn up the pressure if
some confrontation is needed if maybe
somebody needs to be and i say this in
air quotes if people end up seeing the
video or not in air quotes they need to
be shocked into thinking something
differently so yes there are certainly
different areas and opportunities to
approach it differently with people but
that's where it's important that we take
a goal-oriented approach to these
conversations because if i'm thinking to
myself michael's not listening to me i
need to get his attention so i'm going
to ramp it up that's not a goal-oriented
decision that's right ego-oriented
decision right about me not feeling
respected in the moment but if i can
stay focused on the goal what are the
long-term goals i'm looking to achieve
now i can limit my emotional involvement
and i can do a better job choosing when
and how to adapt my approach based on
the goal i'm looking to achieve in the
situation i'm looking to achieve it in
michael this was so cool such a cool
perspective and it sounds like you have
such an awesome job working with leaders
and people on on having better
communication and they can only imagine
how that
doesn't just
stay with their work but also transcends
into the daily lives and and hopefully
one day we get to work together as well
so michael thank you very very much hey
i appreciate this time and your insights
and uh stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much i appreciate you
having me i look forward to it take care
thank you thank you
[Music]